the last time michelle pfeiffer was in a
Tim Burton movie I hit puberty Dark
Shadows is the new Tim Burton Johnny
Depp collaboration they make everything
together they're separated at Birth I
don't know they're they love each other
they just they really like each other
this movies about Barnabas Collins
played by Johnny Depp he was cursed by
Eva green to be immortal to be a vampire
he was locked underground
he was buried underground for 200 years
before some random construction worker
dug him out and now he's in 1972 he has
no idea where he is he's used to the
1700s and this is all very strange for
him he's a fish out of water he knows a
lot of comedy to be had there he wanders
into the woods and he finds his old
estate he used to live at this big
mansion and a few members of his
remaining family are still there and he
decides to try to rekindle the family
business and because of the fact that
he's from the 1700s and oh yeah he's a
vampire there's a lot of comedy to be
had there now let me just say the
trailer for Dark Shadows is very
misleading it really makes it seem like
it's a comedy just a flat-out straight
comedy and I heard the Tim Burton was
very disappointed in that trailer
because it missed marketed the film and
he's absolutely right this is a film
that has comedy throughout the film and
it's funny at times but this is also
very dark and violent actually like I
was very surprised at the places this
film went I enjoyed dark shadows for the
most part I did have some issues with
that I will get to that later but let's
talk about things I like first off
Johnny Depp is a great actor you're
never gonna see a movie and walk out of
the theater going yeah then we just
didn't have Johnny Depp that would have
been so much better he's really good at
transporting himself into these
characters he does a great job in this
movie also I really liked the film's
soundtrack has a lot of good 70 songs
opened with Knights and white satin by
Moody Blues and there was a lot of
really good 70s hits throughout the
movie I liked the soundtrack of the film
it had it a very strange twisted like
just off-kilter vibe to the movie with
all the weird 70s music Eva Green is in
this movie you know from Casino Royale
she plays the girl who curses Johnny
Depp and he of a green man that is one
good-looking woman that is just yes I
also like the fact that this film is not
the girly vampire stories that were so
used to nowadays this is he's a vampire
he shows up and he kills some people and
I was thinking okay now they established
that he killed
people okay they're never gonna do it
again I was wrong he didn't Sparkle at
all in this movie he had meals he
definitely did that this movie is
definitely miss marketed and you will
see a lot of critics who are negatively
reviewing the film because they didn't
think it was funny enough that's not the
film's fault that's the trailers fault
if you watch the trailer and you go into
this movie expecting to be a comedy it's
not a hundred percent comedy definitely
has humor and it for sure it's got funny
moments a lot of them and too many of
them are in the trailer like if you go
to this movie expecting a straight
comedy you're not gonna be happy this
movie clearly isn't trying to be that
it's not the movies fault that these
trailer people just keep miss marketing
movies and disappointing audiences all
around the world because the movie isn't
exactly what they thought it was gonna
be when they watch the trailer that
being said I do have some problems with
this movie namely the character of Vicki
she's the character that we start the
film off with after the opening she is
trying to get a job in this mansion so
through her we see the mansion we meet
these different people Michelle Pfeiffer
who is very good in the movie Chloe
Moretz who is also good in the film but
Vicky is a character that we start out
with and you start learning things about
her and then later I'm not going to get
into spoilers but there's a character
who kind of gets involved with her
romantically and you're supposed to all
of a sudden care about that when she is
just criminally underdeveloped her
character is so important in this story
especially as the film draws to a close
but you really hardly are with her it's
she's just at the very beginning a few
scenes in the middle and also at the end
it's like where it all is coming from
the finale of the film is very exciting
but it asks you to care about certain
characters that are barely developed
throughout the movie and because of that
you're just not really that invested in
it and so I didn't feel any type of
emotional resonance when certain things
were happening because her character was
so poorly developed but I did like this
movie I enjoyed this movie I enjoyed the
performances I liked the way the film
looked it's beautifully shot as a great
score by Danny Elfman performances are
all good it's just that tonally it's
extremely inconsistent the narrative of
the film is really jumpy because humor
and then the dark and the violent and
then you're supposed to care about
certain characters that are really
poorly developed and so the narrative
feels really just yeah like all over the
place nevertheless I enjoyed dark
shadows and because of that I'm gonna
give it a B so let me know what is your
favorite Johnny Depp movie do you have
one because the guy's been in a lot of
movies and he's just he's a great actor
you know but he's been in so much
I don't know a mine is don't even I
can't I'm Terra
those hats but if you liked this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck my eyes
[Music]